好半導體展
又是史上最大規模的
即將要開展了
等一下雲翔哥會告訴您
整體半導體他真的非常喜歡
而裡面的特化股
事實上最近是有股票
在往創高的路上表態的
所以看高做低是蠻多選擇的
這邊來歡迎雲翔哥
因為今天是8月31號
你有一個比了4個月的比賽
今天晚上要公布最後的名次
一起問你機器啦
好然後另外當然除了特化
還有SpaceX概念股
先看一下这个
这个是从那个
应该是五月份
五月份开始比的吗
五月就是这个时间点
这个时间开始比的
五月到八月底
所以四个月
对
然后指数的话
就是说大概是震的10%
因为七月曾经有跌破这个入场点
这一场的话
对 这一场
很多人在这样
大洗牌
对 所以大概四个月
那四个月我那时候大概
初期的投入资金是4000万
先投4000万
对 4000万
不过我可以
融资多少满
也就是说
最大的一个磁场
可以到快1亿
那总资金4000万
收益是250%
因为现在刚好
含今天的话
是刚好破1亿
今天有再砸下去
就对了
对
那不过这一次呢
因为确实比较竞争
因为它这个不是用
收益率来比
不只比收益率
对 它是完全就是
不管你放多少资金
它就比你的收益这样子
比纯收益吗
纯收益 对
那不就是谁有钱
谁的手臂就出吗
对 会比较有这样的
当然也有可能它会亏很多
不过这里来讲
你发现第一名
对 第一名大概
大概这四个月就做了
九百多亿的金页
九百多亿
都快千亿了
第一名是谁
我看一下
LeBron James
什么东西
怎么跟他比
他很有钱
所以他大概收益
到前一天是大概7.5亿
7.5亿的收益
那二三四就很贴近
大概就在一亿左右
对那第五名就大概
掉到七千多万
就拉开了
前十当然都有奖杯
是
不过当然基本上
大家在抢前三嘛
是
所以现在来讲是坐视望山
等一下你为什么
要把你的本名叫冠军操盘手
人家是Loburn Jets
跟文班亚嘛
对
所以确实我就把这个
反正没差啦对就把它列出來那這一次我覺得說當然這個收益一亿这是真正的实单所以那个户头30万的那个户头
目前已经2.28亿了
好 这是实单交易
大家要理解
这个不是虚拟交易
年初我记得是8888
对 所以已经过了2.28亿
所以这里面
刚刚照尔有提到
说大概做什么
其实跟我讲的东西
当然差不多意思了
就是看高做低
然后找一些
大概本益比较
落点比较优的一些标的
就可以稍微有避开
像这波我有避开
其实7月5还是赚的
近期来讲有一个半导地展
应该是明天嘛
对不对
好 8月31号就有论坛
今天有论坛
9月2号后天
对 开始展
那其实这一次来讲
其实围绕了
当然都是跟台信的关联性
非常非常大
这是一定的
对 所以这里面你来看
看就是说大概有几个
然后比较那个
这个是摊位的位置
那基本上第一个来讲
一定是材料
那另外来讲就是封装
对 那封装里面
当然还含了这个面板级的
三处型封装
那这里面来讲就是说
一些高阶的封装
基本上也在
那再来就是设备
设备非常多
这些设备参与非常多
秘密麻麻
对 包括设备
也包括了这些像
这个厂物的部分
也都有进来
对 那设备啊
军华 军豪 蒙利家
基本上跟设备相关都有
材料的话
可能这边展现的没有像最近
有像中华化长新
应该也都会去
看过像长新也有积极在展展
因为它是主要
台阶它主要的一个供应商
所以这个一定有
所以这里面来讲
刚刚提到就是
这个所谓的一个半导体技术特区
记忆体也有
高峰论坛
矽光子太热了
这边也有
所以在这里面来讲
这一次当然汇集了很多
听说厂商有1000多家
历史最高 最多
那我先谈一下
因为大家可能
很久没有去谈到特化
而且他们的位阶高低差异很大
那特化里面
其实最近有很多股票都快创高
因为像中华化 长新
应该都在已经是
历史的一个高点位置
那当然你会发现说
其实特化里面
很多它基本上
它的营收一直有在创高
也代表说确实
你如果跟台積電的供應
關係很強的情況下
那當然它這個創高是無可厚非所以你可以看說像台特化對不對這是台電最大的一個供應那剩衣也是對 剩衣也是
那剩衣大部分的一個供應來講
我等一下會提到
那中華化是它轉型
它等於是
原本是比較傳統的一些化工
它有轉型到一個
等於是電子級的一個部分
所以它基本上收益也開始起來
不過這一面來講
就是剛剛有提到一個
就是說確實
因為很多它的本益比
还是蛮高的
对
中华化来讲
已经大概就是
60倍的一个本益比
所以这里面来讲
当然这里
圣医它的一个本益比来讲
我觉得就是相对还是偏低
大概就18倍
因为它今年
我们大概我记得
去年开始
我们就有大概提到这一支
有提过
那时候有估说
今年应该有到
大概7到8块
因为更好
可能会到9块
因为它的营收一直在创高
对
那毛利也在起来
那我先讲一下就是说
大概以像长新跟中华化
這兩次來講
你會發現它離高點來講
已經大概很接近了
然後他們都是之前從二三十塊
就是很便宜漲上來
現在也還百元下面
落點來講都是從
大概三四十塊左右
這個中華化也是從三十幾塊
曾經拉到一百多塊
現在又來到這個位置點
那當然我覺得說
確實跟它所謂的轉型
因為這樣其實都是比較
從傳統一直過來
長新像它是膠材的部分
那現在也是電子級的一個膠材
對 跟半導體關聯性很大
中文化也一樣
那這裡來講
我就說可以看一下聖益
為什麼
因為聖益基本上來講
就是台積電的供應裡面
它是做大概有切入兩奈米這一塊
它是應該是最先進的
那另外來講
這個是一個最大的一個要件
為什麼
因為它供應台積電
有八項的關鍵材料裡面
有四項是獨家
獨家供應
有三項是等於是
兩個供應鏈而已
只有兩個供應商
那這四個裡面包含什麼
就是說像去光阻劑
光阻基本上當然是
清洗殘渣的光阻劑
玻璃劑
就是把一些特殊材料把它移除
另外來講一些高階的清洗劑
清洗劑這一塊也是
所以大概有四項是所謂的獨家
另外三項來講
就是二工的話大概這兩個
IPA來講也就是
比較先進的所謂的一個
一個特化的一個部分
電子級的特化那這個來講它的100%投資的一個宏盛來講大概投資了23億擴擴在張濱這個產線來講已經開始要投產那PM這個也是
PM跟IPA都是在這個三項裡面的
一個其中的一項
所以這個產能來講
從5萬噸到17萬噸
等於是增了三倍
所以滿載後的年增率
大概會增加50億
50億它股本才30億
所以這一塊來講
我認為說明年
它的一个成长会更高
所以以这样的情况看来
就是说今年9块
我觉得明年
一定是突破10块钱以上
所以现在来讲100多块
我觉得是真的还是
未接还是可以
但是你这个轨道
会不会画太大了
我不得不讲
这轨道也太大了
它其实一直走在了
一些一个上升轨道
是确实的
因为对它来讲
你会发现说它还蛮稳的
虽然它没有这种
直喷的一个感觉
可是这个是还原后
它曾经有来到204元
好 还原后
对 204元
也是破过200块了
那这一波
它的这一块的位置点
也是在7月份以后
有瞬间一个拉回
我觉得都是一个好机会
因为拉回以后
又回到这个
所谓上升轨道的
一个下云的位置点
那我觉得说
如果以这样的情况下来
就是说140几
在过去来讲
它曾经有在一年
等于是快一年
年初的时候
也曾经有来到这样的
180的一个位置
所以160几
我觉得说
以目前来讲
你都已经知道说
它的业绩成长情况下
我觉得这个落点应该还算低
好 轨道线的下源
对
至少可以在轨道间做
对 我觉得说做的话
你看它的高点落点
大概快200
也是
对 也就是历史的一个高点位置
好 那另外一块来讲
我觉得Specs也是可以注意
对 因为这个来讲
等于是未来几年
一直会是一个热点
是 没有想到美股
也可以走得像这样
沉线
而且它的那個K棒超級小的
因為確實來
因為很多人當然很多
我們講說
大概台灣人也很多
套在這個所謂的
大概大概170以上
可能150、170
對 都有了
那我覺得說
以目前這個位界來講
看起來就是說
它一直在釋出一些利多
對 因為以大摩加碼說
目標就要看300
那當然300也不是說無所本
它基本上講的是說
它基本上2028年
它的營收會增長70%
是
對 那為什麼這張70%
他認為說第一個來講
當然他美國
這個國防部還是有支持他
光國防訂單來講
這有80.5億
再來一個就是說
〔此段辨識失敗，約 10:00 起〕